thanks to trade coffee for keeping legal
eagle in the air because you would not
want to see me before my first cup of
joe am i right
courage gallegos asks are you a sith
lord
wouldn't you like to know
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to celebrate
actually because
just a little while ago this channel
crossed a million subscribers and
roughly at the same time it crossed a
hundred million video views
i'm absolutely floored i can't believe
that this channel that was
started as a hobby just because i got
mad at the tv
when people were getting the law wrong
on tv and movies
has expanded into a channel where a
million of you have signed up
to hear more about the law
and to learn more about how to think
like a lawyer and to learn more about
the laws that surround us
every day so from the bottom of my heart
thank you
so much it's been an honor and a
pleasure to
create this channel and i'm so honored
that so many of you have decided to come
along for the ride and
since i can't throw a big party where i
can invite all of you
for various incredibly obvious reasons
right now
i thought the best way that we could
celebrate is to celebrate all of you
guys because i
couldn't have done this without you so i
asked for the questions that you might
have about
legal eagle the channel about me
personally or about life
in general so let's answer some of those
questions
and talk about just what it is you guys
want to know
the first question is from nate myers
who asks
in what ways has your youtube channel
affected your job your life in general
as if there's any distinction between my
life and my job
those are definitely one and the same so
in terms of how the youtube channel has
affected the job
not all that much actually day-to-day
practicing law
the fact that i have a youtube channel
doesn't really change very much
sometimes i get recognized but usually
not at all
and frankly uh the main way that the
youtube channel has affected
my professional life is that it just
takes a huge amount of time
to be able to do these videos i think
that every video if we're talking about
a substantive legal issue
takes roughly 10 to 20 hours to research
and outline
another one to four hours
to shoot and then another 10 to 20 hours
to
edit and review and edit again and go
back and forth now
i'm not doing the video editing anymore
um but still that's a huge amount of
time to sort of go back and supervise
and that sort of stuff so
for better or worse the youtube channel
is starting to crowd out my
uh professional legal and business life
so that's definitely something i have to
take into consideration but
it's something that i absolutely love i
have
the best job in the world to have this
channel
and uh to be able to make creative
videos i mean semi-creative that they're
about the law after all but
uh to be able to make these videos uh as
part of my professional life
is just the best thing in the world um
and and uh it's a lot of hard work but
it's also
incredibly fulfilling and satisfying as
well kieran o'sullivan asks does the
fact that most criminal cases are
settled with plea deals bother you given
the power and balance between the
defendant and state
i'd say yes and no there's always going
to be a power imbalance between
the government the state and the people
especially individuals and especially
people who are tend to be in lower
socioeconomic
conditions but i think that we can and
often have done things that help make it
a little bit more
fair under the the gideon case all
criminal defendants are entitled to
representation that's what public
defenders are there for i think that
public defenders
do a great service to individuals and to
the country and and
they should receive more funding and the
fact that
things are often settled through plea
deals
is not necessarily the worst thing we
don't want to have to spend huge amounts
of resources on criminal trials
every time there is an accusation of
criminal conduct obviously there are
going to be times when
people take a plea deal because it's the
expedient thing to do or because
they're not willing to fight it out in
court but often that's just a more
efficient way
people are going to get less of a
criminal sentence through a plea deal
than they would if they took things to
court so
no system is perfect certainly the
american criminal justice system
is far from perfect um but to the extent
that there is injustice it's up to all
of us to
make it better and we certainly can
there's a lot of things that we can do
and we've talked about that on this
channel there's a lot that we can and i
think will be done in the future
movie squad asks have you ever received
criticism from other lawyers for hosting
a youtube channel well first of all i
have so many lawyer friends
uh and they're all very supportive of
the channel um and a few people
have expressed to me that legal eagle is
the channel that they wish they had
started so
beat you to it that being said uh in
real life the the support is
uh pretty unanimous and uh for the most
part i think people
recognize that i am trying to explain
fairly uncontroversial legal issues
in the news and that legal literacy is
something that
for better or worse a lot of people need
that being said
online i have received lots of criticism
from political pundits
uh from other attorneys um
who may or may not have done their
research uh and
from a lot of people who claim to be
attorneys
online i am a little suspicious of a lot
of those comments that claim to have
done the research or have studied this
topic for dozens of years
uh but uh yeah for the most part i think
the criticism
is uh is generally well-meaning um or
just
incredibly misinformed michaela p
asks who is the wii at legal eagle how
big
is the team in the background so i am so
so lucky to have a few individuals who
help me out
uh every day and frankly where this
channel is now would not be possible
without the people that i work with i
have two main video editors amy and
chris
who do a fantastic job and often on
insane deadlines i am constantly amazed
at how quickly
chris and amy can turn out some of these
videos and
and frankly how polished everything is
if you see the the 2d graphics that are
on the screen and they'll like fly in
and fly out or
the full screen graphics uh i have no
idea how to do that that's all motion
graphics that's done in adobe after
effects i can
edit together a video if i need to but i
am totally incapable of doing
what amy and chris do i just simply give
them comments and and tell them that i
want more of this
or less of that
and they make it happen in addition to
that i work with two amazing attorneys
andrea
and rob who often do a huge amount of
legal research when
there is uh a topic where i'm not a
subject matter
expert for example the video i did on
posse comitatus that is not
a law that i deal with on an everyday
basis and there's like one guy
who has ever done any research on that
particular topic
often i need help with some of the
research and andrea and rob
are incredibly amazing when it comes to
helping out with
uh actually researching these sometimes
very arcane
and archaic laws that because of the
times that we live in
uh somehow rear their ugly head and we
have to figure out
uh what uh what's going to happen and
what the legal confines are of the
various situations that we deal with i
also work with some amazing animators
alex and nick who are responsible
largely for
the animated series the the case of that
deals with various true crime related
things so that's the lion's share of the
team over here at legal eagle i'm hoping
to
expand i'm hoping to be able to do more
videos which may require that the team
get even
larger definitely would not be possible
by myself
and i'm i'm so indebted to having such
an incredible team and
i'm looking forward to working with them
in the future on this ashman rich
asks everyone out here asking
hard-hitting questions and i'm
interested in one thing
pineapple on pizza yay or nay and why
man i mean that is a that is a hard
hitting question too i do
enjoy a pizza with pineapple on it on
occasion
i would say i much prefer generally
speaking a neapolitan
pizza with uh added uh onions i'm i'm a
onion on pizza
guy but there's definitely a time and a
place for
a pizza with a little sweetness added to
it got no problem with that
all right nick hunder asks sometimes you
have to represent the bad guy in a case
in those situations how do you stay
neutral in order to best represent your
client
so i actually sort of disagree with the
premise
of this particular question a lot of my
career
has been spent in the the civil side of
things uh the
vast majority of it in fact and the
majority of that is spent
on civil defense although i have spent a
fair amount of time doing
civil plaintiff work as well i was
definitely prepared at coming out of law
school
to represent someone who was a quote
bad guy or more likely someone who was
wrong what i found actually is that in
every single case i ever had
all of my clients and really if unfair
the other uh uh people that we were up
against
had colorable legal arguments if you
file a lawsuit or you have to deal with
a lawsuit or you're getting into
litigation
um odds are the case is somewhere on the
margins
such that each side is going to have
reasonable arguments
and when you have reasonable arguments
it's
easy to see why your client should win
the case now sometimes those legal
arguments are more of a
technicality frankly if a client was
clearly in the wrong
then often it's the role of the lawyer
to
to tell them that they should not fight
this particular case often that's why
uh their the vast majority of cases
actually
settle out of court so if there was a
rare instance where i didn't feel like
the client had a a leg to stand on
then almost certainly that client uh
would have
settled and and gotten out of the
lawsuit that way
if you get into multi-million dollar
litigation
and you keep going forward and you get
to trial the reason that you're in trial
is because both sides
think they can win so that's actually
the rarity to actually
get that far into a case for the most
part
if people were did something wrong
they're going to settle and try and get
out as quickly as possible
sergey niskanen says how can one become
a judge are there some special law
schools for that or is it more a
question of long-term legal practice and
general experience
or maybe there are some very specific
requirements have you ever considered a
judicial career for yourself
uh so how do you become a judge well
that depends on the jurisdiction
some are appointed by the governor or
the president and some
are elected depends on where you live
and the particular court you're dealing
with
no special law schools any law school
will do though
going to a higher ranked law school
makes you more likely to become
a judge i would probably say though when
you are appointed to be a judge often
certain states and the federal system
will send you to judge school because
often people don't know what they're
doing and sort of a crash course and
actually being a judge so technically
there is sort of a special
judge school and i have absolutely no
aspirations of becoming a judge myself
i am very very thankful that we have a
lot of good judges out there but that is
definitely not something i would want to
do myself
all right let's uh let's do some rapid
fire questions i think i've been taking
this
way too seriously and i want to get
through a bunch more of these questions
so let's let's try and do it
christopher miller asks when did it
become comfortable speaking in front of
a judge
i have never had a problem speaking in
front of a judge i think that dates back
to
doing um speech and debate in high
school and
actually frankly in middle school and
maybe elementary school i did a bunch of
speech competitions so
i have always been very very comfortable
speaking in front of a crowd and
you know it judges just like a crowd but
it's one person and they're very very
powerful
okay zayn woollett asks when can i get a
t-shirt that says the bailiff will
tackle you i don't know i
i'm not totally sold on merch yet maybe
someday
let me know if you guys want that or
like tie clips or
uh i'm very particular about a
very special kind of legal pad so if you
guys would want
legal eagle legal pads uh let me know uh
maybe merch is in the future i could
definitely make that happen
kelp shaw asks why did you become a
lawyer and then stop to do youtube seems
to me a lawyer would be an easier job
well i haven't stopped being a lawyer i
still practice all the time though
youtube is definitely taking up a larger
and larger
portion of my day-to-day life which is
awesome because
youtube is really really creative who
gets to make creative video essays all
day long you know being a lawyer
is great uh i love it i always wanted to
be a lawyer but also
the deadlines are terrible in the sense
that sometimes if you miss a deadline
your client is screwed and to live under
the damocles of
these looming deadlines man that is no
fun at least in youtube if you
miss a video by a day uh is not
jurisdictional and you get kicked off of
youtube that can happen in real life as
a lawyer so
uh you know youtube is fun try monster
asks what is a part of your job that
people
typically don't realize lawyers do i
would say
probably telling them not to sue or that
a lawsuit
is not in their best interest or telling
them that they
don't want me to actually go forward and
be as aggressive as possible
a lot of people see lawyers on tv and
they assume that
the best thing to do is to always sue
and to always be incredibly aggressive
that's actually rarely the case and
sometimes
something is not worth suing over you
might have been wronged but
it's not worth it to spend tens of
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of dollars on attorneys
sometimes there are amicable ways of
settling things that
are actually net positives for both
sides and so
a lot of a lawyer's job is not just as
a zealous advocate but also as a
business person to help two sides come
together and to find
a mutually amicable solution uh let's
see jonathan chang
asks when you doing the collab with dr
mike
when dr mike responds if i need to stand
outside of his apartment
uh with a boombox over my head like john
cusack to make that happen
i will totally do that dr mike is
awesome you should definitely watch his
channel and
i hope someday we get to collaborate
courage gallegos asks are you a sith
lord
wouldn't you like to know alright
susannah asks i'm a high school student
and have considered becoming a lawyer
but i'm unsure
what are some ways i can know if being a
lawyer is the right career i should go
into
well a couple of things number one you
can do mock trial in high school i did
uh mock trial all through high school
college and law school
while it's not the greatest
representation of the day-to-day life of
a lawyer it will give you a taste for
litigation
and it will make you a better public
speaker and it will help you think on
your feet
in addition to that pay attention in
english class
what lawyers really do every day is
right
they write and write and write they'll
do some research and then they'll write
some more
and so being a lawyer is more about
being a great writer than it is being a
great public speaker
generally speaking if that appeals to
you then law school might be
the way to go pedro 4816 asks
are you going to read all the comments
including this one
yes idiot asks since you've looked at a
lot of legal movies
what do you think makes a legal movie
enjoyable while still being accurate
while i am happy to criticize legal
movies for their accuracy
legal accuracy is not the most important
thing for me when i'm watching a legal
movie i think the dialogue needs to be
good and most importantly
the characters need to grow basically
everything that happens in the plot is
really just in service of
helping the protagonist or the
antagonist grow as a person
and that i think is the most important
thing sometimes legal accuracy totally
gets in the way of that
but sometimes you'll get a show like
better call saul that is able to tell
amazing stories while still being
legally accurate and that's super cool
too
cool guy not full guy asks stupid
question but why did you choose the name
legal eagle
because eagles are cool and it rhymes
and as one of the comments pointed out
unlawful falafel
doesn't have the same ring to it okay
edward zhang asks to add to the question
of your specialty in law what made you
decide on this particular specialty i'm
a prospective law student and having a
hard time figuring out what i want to
specialize in well
in a way i haven't really specialized i
am
a litigator and trial lawyer so i guess
my specialty is the process the process
of
the lawsuit the process of going to
trial but in terms of the substantive
law that i deal with
it has varied widely it includes
copyrighting
includes class action defense it
includes contracts business
ip banking and it's great that every day
i get to research something new it keeps
things fresh and that's one of the
things i love about this particular
channel is that
i get to do research into new parts of
the law to become a momentary expert
about these particular things so that i
can explain
the law to other people so in some ways
i haven't had to specialize and
that's one of the things that i think is
great about being a litigator and or
trial lawyer bren s asks what was your
proudest moment as a lawyer
there was one case where i was dealing
with the
worst opposing counsel i have ever dealt
with in my entire life
just the biggest jerk i've ever had the
misfortune to go up against
and when i beat the pants off of that
guy i was really really happy about that
because he deserved to lose and he
deserved to get smacked down by the
court if i
remember correctly he was sanctioned by
the court which doesn't happen all that
often
it's a little petty but man not going to
deny it
it felt really really good olivier
coravar asks what is an important thing
about law you wish everyone understood
this is going to sound strange coming
from a lawyer
but just because something is legal or
illegal doesn't mean it's morally right
or morally wrong
which is one of the reasons why law is
so bound up
in politics the end result of politics
is law
we always have to stay vigilant to make
sure that our laws reflect
uh our society and and justice
okay jonathan chang asks how old are you
man i've always wondered that i am 36
thank you for asking valerio asks if you
hadn't become a lawyer what other
profession job would you have had or
liked to do
before i wanted to be a lawyer there was
a very brief amount of time where i
wanted to be
an architect in my spare time i often do
a bunch of home renovations
i really like the idea of playing with
space and you know making your home
nicer so i think
if i wasn't a lawyer i'd probably be a
an architect
or a contractor doing renovation stuff
which
is kind of a hobby of mine and finally
ipancake asks what led you to doing
youtube in addition to being a lawyer
funny story so when i was in high school
my senior
english teacher gave us the option to
either write
an essay or to do a final project as
a video project well hello there
i'm devin stone me and my three best
friends
thought writing an essay was sounded
terrible so we decided to do
this video project that turned into this
huge thing that became an
hour long where we satirized every piece
of english literature that we read
that year in class sorry sweetheart i
have another mistress
[Music]
her name is justice i'm actually still
really proud of this
we did macbeth as celebrity jeopardy
once again this is alex trebek for
celebrity jeopardy
saying good night good night
we did jane austen's pride and prejudice
as a soap opera called the proud and the
prejudiced
i think it's it's still really good so
that really
got me interested in video editing and i
didn't really pick it up again until
much later i wanted to start a channel
where i helped
law students get through law school
because i had a really good time in law
school i thought it was really fun
and i had a lot of tips and tricks for
people to do well in law school
so i started legal eagle as a way to
help current and future law students
and that sort of snowballed into what
you see today where i expanded it not
just to tips about law school but just
explaining the law in general so that's
how i got started with
youtube it's been a crazy ride and i
guess i might as well
tell you what's next for the channel for
the near future we're going to be
doubling down
there are so many legal issues uh that
we have to discuss
so many things that happen in the news
and so i would really like to be able to
do more videos
over the last few months given that uh
everyone has been sort of confined to
their house
i've been able to find some time and get
more videos out which
has helped the channel grow and i would
like to be able to do that on a
permanent basis
uh if not two videos a week then perhaps
three videos every two weeks
i'd like to expand out different formats
of videos i have a bunch of ideas of
things that are related to the channel
but i haven't been able to touch on yet
maybe some more humorous content and if
you have ideas about
how you'd like to see that expansion
going i'm all ears and like i said it's
so much
fun to be able to do these videos and
it's so rewarding to know that
that some people find this information
valuable
of course people ask me how i have the
time to be able to do these things
and the answer is because i drink a lot
of coffee and consume a lot of caffeine
which is why i'm so thrilled
that trade coffee is the sponsor of
today's video
these days i am basically fueled by
coffee and rage
trade coffee in particular is great
because not only do they have a huge
selection of
your favorite coffees but they have an
awesome quiz to get matched to coffee
recommendations based on your taste
preferences
i myself like a sweeter full-bodied
chocolatey
coffee and while i don't drink coffee
every day
mainly on days when i have to film hours
and hours worth of videos
i want my coffee to actually taste good
and with trade you can discover new
coffees from the nation's best coffee
roasters and
trade matches you to your own personal
selection of coffee and conveniently
delivers it straight to you so
you don't have to leave the house to go
into a supermarket there might be
reasons why
you might not want to do that under the
circumstances so trade will get you the
best coffees at the best price and
deliver them
straight to your door the first 100
legal eagles will get 30
off their first bag when they sign up
and you get free shipping
so just click on the link in the
description take the coffee quiz at
trade coffee
and choose your frequency whether you
want one bag or a subscription
and then rate your coffee so your
suggestions will get even better you can
even choose
whole beans or your preferred grind it
really is the best coffee website out
there so to get 30
off of your first order at trade coffee
click on the link in the description
or use the promo code legal30 at
checkout clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so thank
you for sticking with me
if you want to see some more videos of
mine click over here i've got a whole
bunch of legal reactions
explaining legal things in the news so
click on this playlist
i'll see you in court and thanks a
million